ich habe heute etwas mitgebracht was
mich nicht aufträgt sondern zum
nachdenken anregt und mich interessiert
heute sehr was die runde dazu denkt und
zwar geht es um weitere features morgen
gibt es wieder eine klima demonstration
in berlin dabei wird auch sein greta to
work das idol der jugend das klima idol
verstehen sie mich nicht falsch bei
meinen nächsten ausführungen ich find's
großartig wenn die jugend sich für etwas
einsetzt wenn die jugend politisch
interessiert ist wenn sie für etwas
stehen und etwas kämpft mit leidenschaft
mein problem mit facebooks future ist
nur ich empfinde es so dass vor allem
auch in ihm sei neubauer zu wenig an
demokratischen prozessen interessiert
ist es ist immer klimawandel jetzt wir
müssen ihn schaffen aber wie machen wir
das die umsetzung scheint mir auffiel zu
fern und ich würde mir so oft bei price
for future
magnetismus und weniger ideologie
wünschen ein beispiel als leser neubauer
auf kevin kühnert traf um eine
eigentlich denken bei sind sich bestimmt
noch ein der in der argumentation hat
kevin kühnert auf die demokratischen
prozesse hingewiesen in der klimawandel
auch zu stemmen ist und frau neubauer
hat einfach nur genervt den kopf
geschüttet aber uns gelingt doch nur der
klimawandel mit der demokratie und ich
würde mir wünschen dass freude es for
future langsam den kinderschuhen
entwächst und etwas weniger mit dem kopf
durch die wand will und etwas mehr auch
schaut ja was es eigentlich möglich und
schüler sollten nicht mehr fürs klima
die schule schwänzt hinzu also lena ich
muss dich direkt mal wieder sprechen es
tut mir leid ich muss es so sagen
völliger quatsch also also dressieren
sie sich für demokratische prozesse
erstmals ist und zweitens ja es gibt
auch im klimaprozess menschen die über
die stränge schlagen aber extrem
rebellion ist nicht fair dass fünf user
und zwei des sofioter ist für mich
demokratie in ihrer reinsten form also
da lernen und auch junge menschen sich
einzubringen sich für ihre ziele
einzusetzen dass sie etwas bewegen
können ich finde dass das
demokratischste überhaupt in den letzten
jahren und jahrelang wurde uns jungen
menschen vorgeworfen dass wir zu faul
sind einzusetzen das finde ich an
politik interessiert sind und jetzt tun
welche was und jetzt solltest
demokratiefeindlich sein also die isu
hingegen hat den euro heute angeschaut
ja und er war immer da natürlich hin und
das sind halt demokratische prozesse und
kann man nicht machen ich finde es
wichtig die uhr tickt ja es ist fünf
nach zwölf oder sogar berg glaube ich
die uhr tickt das ist das was mich bei
diesem ganzen protest extrem stört das
ist die monstranz mit der der junge
leute meinen sie haben das recht
komplett auf ihrer seite und die große
frage zum beispiel ein thema klimaschutz
das ist ja kein thema was jetzt kreta
thunberg als erstes in vechta es gibt
schon länger die frage ist hat sich das
nochmal beschleunigt hatte klaus töpfer
ja
aber
der punkt ist doch wenn ich einmal zu
ende machen darf der punkt ist doch es
gibt klimaziele und interessanterweise
wurden die klimaziele 2020 sogar
erreicht der schadstoff und ja das ist
und das macht man nicht gerne hören
amelie vielleicht magst du das auch
nicht aber das ziel was man sich 1990
gegeben hat oder den 90ern im vergleich
zum jahr 1990 ist 2020 erreicht worden
die reduktion des schadstoffausstoßes
und 40 prozent ist erreicht also so zu
tun es wäre noch nie was passiert dr wie
können sie es wagen alles falsch
deutschland hat sein klimaziel bereit na
ja also ich
finde erst mal
für die schon den aktivisten rund um
greta thonberg und dieser respekt zollen
dass sie sich eines solchen themas
angenommen haben und das im bewusstsein
haben um den zustand unserer welt aber
es tut doch hier jeder ich meine sind
wir dann nicht mehr zu ändern gewesen
das ist doch nicht so dass gnade
erkennen wie das gewinnen geht an ihm
vorbei
ausgeschenkt haben wir doch alle davor
es geht ja nicht nur um respekt es geht
um die dringlichkeit die auch von der
wissenschaft ganz klar in den raum
gestellt wird es geht um das allgemeine
bewusstsein wir leben doch in einer zeit
in der eine krise die nächste jagt in
der wir sozusagen lauter short
extensions pants sind die im grunde
genommen heute bei dem thema sind morgen
wieder beim anderen thema wir merken
auch dass er medial nicht in der lage
sind in einem wahlkampf team so zu
setzen dass wir die bevölkerung
mitnehmen
gucken was die themen waren die in
diesem wahlkampf vorrangig behandelt wo
der neuen revue die cdu ja also und
entschuldige bitte ganz kurz wir hatten
mit der wir hatten das lachen von armin
laschet was wirklich ausgeschlachtet
wurde wir hatten die situation um
annalena baerbock aber warum ich das
alles aufzählen ist ich finde es gut
dieses thema so aktivistisch oben
aufzuhängen und tatsächlich aber auf der
anderen seite auch das problem das
problem ist dass man irgendwann einen
punkt kommt wo man dann vielleicht auch
mal wieder die geschichtsbücher rhein
gucken kann und dann zum gedanken kommt
was rudi dutschke damals gesagt hat den
marsch durch die institutionen
irgendwann reicht es nicht nur zu
fordern und leute anzutreiben irgendwann
muss nur zu einem punkt kommen wo man
sagt okay wir müssen selber gestalten
und das kann man halt nicht abwehren und
der parlamentarische prozess ist ein
ganz mühevoller das habe ich selber
gemerkt mich haben ja auch dinge
angetrieben was verändern zu wollen und
bis ich mich bis ich aufgestellt wurde
in spandau und diesen weg gegangen wenn
es wirklich nicht
vergnügungssteuerpflichtig
und da sage ich dass die aktivisten
irgendwann von der rolle der
protestierenden wegmüssen und hin zu
gestalten werden sollten und das relativ
bald auch wenn die dringlichkeit des
klimas ihre stimme jetzt noch braucht
das war jetzt sehr privaten premier für
irgendwas aber ich mein respekt für ihre
regeln der politik wir haben mit
gekommen das ist nicht einfach gewesen
ausstellen zu lassen in spandau wir
drücken die daumen dass wir ganz
persönlich aber was ist nun hat das habe
ich jetzt wirklich nicht verstanden aber
vielleicht nochmal zu dem punkt von nina
schenk zurückzukommen es ist ja so dass
den frei bis fünf user
gruppen ja unterstellt würde ich noch
nicht mal sagen dass gesagt wird ihr
habt es nicht so mit der demokratie bei
dieser gemeinsamen brief von greta
thunberg und einigen anderen der vor
einem jahr veröffentlicht worden ist
schon ein bisschen radikal ist in der
formulierung und sagt na ja wir müssen
das system infrage stellten sie sagen es
gibt aber auch in diesem brief ein ein
bekenntnis zur demokratie den gibt es
auch aber sie sagen das ganze system
müssen wir in frage stellen und daher
kommt das natürlich ganz spannend ist
aber was parallel passiert wir haben
gerade in dubai die größte gas messe der
welt sehr stattfindet und die leute der
opec chef und so die sagen was man auf
freunde sowie ihr euch das vorstellt
funktioniert das alles nicht weil ihr
könnt nicht den kompletten umstieg haben
von heute auf morgen
keine anderen energien bereitstellen aus
der atomkraft aussteigen in die
gaskraftwerke abstellen aus der kohle
aussteigen und dann auch noch alle
e-autos abfahren da brauchen wir für 50
jahre eine transformation und verein ist
für futures sagt in aller radikalität
das geht nicht nur wir müssen den
umstieg jetzt machen mit aller
konsequenz und dass wir am ende sehen
ist jemand wie peter altmaier sagte dann
drosseln doch man den strom man darf
halt nicht jeder tanken zu jeder zeit
ein vorschlag wie man dann schnell
wieder kassiert hat weil er natürlich
abstrus ist aber das einzige was uns
bleibt im moment also ich finde das
peinlich muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen wie
sich viele politiker beifall dass sich
auch angehört haben ja das war dieses
mitlaufen von kritikern in der ersten
reihe der muss sagen das finde ich
peinlich finde das auch bewundernswert
auf eine art und weise dass man sich als
schüler dann doch selbst freigibt vom
unterricht und sagt wichtiger als was zu
lernen ist für das klima zu
demonstrieren das kann man so machen
kann man aber freitags auch um 15 uhr
machen sich auch dann mehr
aufmerksamkeit
garantiert aber das thema ist oft genug
beleuchtet worden ist
schwester mein bruder mein kind
aufpassen dass wir nicht in so einen
arroganten topf kommen so also entspannt
ehrlich gesagt wir dürfen nicht arrogant
habe ich finde schon man darf schon
sagen okay wir sind jetzt an dem punkt
und ich habe ja von anfang an gesagt ich
finde es toll und natürlich müssen wir
respekt zollen dass sie sich eingesetzt
haben aber ich finde langsam sollte auch
frau neubauer und auch frau to work & co
mehr demut haben und auch mal ein wenig
und ich finde nur protestieren ist auch
einfach es ist nur zu sagen gab ich
schlecht dann wird die schleuniger jetzt
lass uns doch mal ganz kurz ich werde
jetzt mich jetzt in christlichen
feindesliebe üben und nicht nur darauf
erwidern was sehen wir gerade zugeworfen
haben aber jetzt schauen wir uns doch
einfach mal dieses teure mann
wird jetzt gerade ja aber jetzt spüre
dann aber jetzt mal ganz im ernst wir
haben doch dieses jahr das können wir
doch nicht wegreden phänomene erlebt die
superkraft sind wenn wir uns die
ostküste in kanada anschauen wenn wir
noch diese flut hat das hat er hier
kinder mussten ganze drei mal ganz kurz
das mal zu ende für also wenn man diese
ganze flutkatastrophe man sich vor augen
vergegenwärtigt was angerichtet hat wir
haben dürrekatastrophen an vielen teilen
dieser welt wir haben überall brände wir
merken dass die erde nicht ruhig mal ein
bisschen pathetisch aus meint ja und wir
haben als menschen der verantwortung
etwas zu tun und diese form der
problemlösung oder problem bewusst
machen dass machen in der radikalität
macht dass die nächste generation und
zwar aus gutem grund weil sie nämlich
sagen das ist unsere welt in der wir
leben wollen ihr hinterlasst uns nicht
die welt wo wir glücklich werden und
eigentlich versuchen wir doch alles zu
tun damit die nächste generation
glücklich wird ja aber und deswegen
glaube ich dass es auf der einen seite
deswegen habe ich das doch die mit dem
marsch der institution bewusst so gesagt
also es ist tatsächlich nur antihaltung
usw das dass das bringt nichts man muss
sich dann wirklich engagieren und man
muss natürlich auch mit den
demokratischen instrumenten arbeiten und
wirkliche realität dass er bereit ist
war schon seit einigen tagen ist frei
das wirtschaftlich zweite sind habe ich
meine worte bewusst gewählt ich finde
jetzt ist die zeit wo sie den
kinderschuhen entwachsen sollten und
schon auch darauf eingehen sollten was
machbar und wenn man sich die fakten
auch mal angucken also deutschland hat
das pariser klimaabkommen immer erfüllt
und teilweise sogar über erfüllt alle
parteien außerhalb der afd wollen den
klimawandel die wollen was dafür tun wir
sind jetzt nicht das schlimmste land im
endeffekt das muss weltweit gelöst
werden weil wenn man sich die fakten
anschaut bin ich ehrlich verstehe ich
manchmal die panikmache nicht ich finde
auch jetzt mit dem klimaschutzgesetz hat
zu lange gedauert würde ich jetzt auch
sagen es hätte früher kommen sind wir da
auf einem guten weg aber wir müssen doch
auch sehen die wirtschaft wir brauchen
auch unsere wirtschaft ohne die
wirtschaft werden wir den klimawandel
nicht schaffen 100% deswegen glaube ich
müssen wir doch jetzt und warum kampfes
verfügt kann ich jetzt und das ist ja
meine bitte
jetzt sagen okay das war wichtig die
proteste aber jetzt lasst uns in
gesprächen und immer wenn ich selber auf
einem dieser neubau des tri fast vor
arroganz man ist nicht zum gespräch
bereit die ok da bin ich da gehe ich
sogar mit dass ich sage auf der einen
seite ist bewusst machen ist das andere
aber dann auch dann wirklich in der
lösungs instrumente setzen wie zum
beispiel innovation ja das ist ja das
ist genau der punkt an dem sie sagen
also wer muss einmal fest haben glaube
ich auch für klimaschützer geht das
grundgesetz das ist ganz entscheidend
und am ende sind es immer nur reiche und
wohlhabende länder die sich auch
klimaschutz leisten können also wenn wir
anfangen auf dem ast wegen der unseren
wohlstand am ende aus macht also auch
die ganze debatte um die frage autos
verbiete ich den verbrennungsmotor oder
was sie nun auch gerade in der tat
richtig glaube ich sagt erlaube ich
innovationen dann sind wir auf den
unterschiedlichen pfad es laufen bei
files for future ganz ganz viele
personen mit die den kapitalismus
beenden wollen dann auch genau wir haben
wir müssen nur 30 jahre zurückschauen im
ostblock habe genau gesehen was passiert
wenn der kapitalismus ausgeknockt ist
das war das gegenteil eines umwelt
paradieses das war eine umwelt wüste und
deswegen glaube ich
ist das was bei friends for future es
passiert vielleicht ein anfang auch
begrüßenswert gewesen aber es nimmt eine
richtung ein die gefährlich ist für
unsere wirtschaft und am ende damit auch
für den klimaschutz
[Musik]